you're gonna love this Donald Trump is
now claiming super conveniently that the
emoluments Clause of the Constitution
just doesn't apply to his hotels
including of course his now infamous
Washington DC hotel we've talked about
the term kleptocracy before and how we
have one in the United States a
kleptocracy of course is a government
with corrupt leaders they are the
kleptocrats that use their power to
exploit the people and natural resources
of their own territory in order to
extend their personal wealth and
political powers typically this system
involves embezzlement of funds at the
expense of the wider population and one
of the ways that this is invisible under
Donald Trump is that trumps personally
profiting from his hotels as president
of the United States specifically
because of the decisions that are being
made by foreign diplomats and leaders to
stay at his hotels for example in
washington d c-- world diplomats go to
washington d.c they say they're staying
at trump's DC hotel in order to curry
favor with him and trump personally
makes money from that directly then we
have to say well is trump giving the
diplomats favorable treatment as a
result but it actually doesn't even
matter you don't even need to prove that
Trump is treating people better because
they stay at his hotel the violation of
the emoluments clause is that he is
receiving things of value from them by
virtue of them choosing to stay at his
hotel this very clearly violates the
emoluments clause to the Constitution
which says quote no title of nobility
shall be granted by the United States
and no person holding any office of
profit or trust under them shall without
the consent of the Congress accept any
present emolument meaning a thing of
value office or title of any kind
whatever from any King prince or foreign
state so that's what we knew up until
like yesterday and it's now been
revealed that Donald Trump's Justice
Department is reinterpreting the
emoluments clause to exempt Donald
hotels thanks to a guardian report we've
learned that there is a June 2017 filing
by the Justice Department which would
allow the President to accept unlimited
amounts of money from foreign
governments as long as it comes through
commercial transactions so I'll sort of
explain the insanity of this up until
now it has been widely understood that
the emoluments clause says you just
can't receive anything of value from
foreign governments or from foreign
officials or monarchs or whoever period
whether they are under the table bribes
or whether they are commercial
transactions known to line the pockets
of a federal elected official and the
way that this was interpreted up until
the current Justice Department is if a
Saudi diplomat shows up in the United
States and slides Trump a million in
cash under the table that's not allowed
but along the same lines if a Saudi
diplomat shows up and spends a million
dollars at Trump's hotel by renting the
entire hotel for a month or whatever
right I mean doesn't matter exactly what
the numbers are that's also not allowed
the new interpretation of the emoluments
Clause means that as long as the money
gets to trump through commercial
transactions with businesses that Donald
Trump owns or profits from it's okay
you can bribe the president as long as
it's happening through actual businesses
in commercial transactions which is
super convenient and made making this
even worse the emoluments clause anyway
like aside from this reinterpretation by
Trump's Justice Department the
emoluments clause doesn't have an anti
money laundering provision in it which
means that if you're a president and you
don't even have a commercial interest
that's suitable for foreign diplomats to
funnel money to you you can create some
straw business like oh I sell
gold-plated water bottles for $10,000
each or whatever it's not a business
that exists for any reason other than to
serve as a mechanism through which you
can launder foreign emoluments a foreign
entity can then come in and say hey
guess what we're buying a thousand of
those gold-plated water bottles from
your busy
and it's a slight cartoonish
exaggeration but this is actually the
problem with the emoluments clause which
it doesn't have an anti laundering
provision and now we've learned that
trumps Justice Department is ignoring it
anyway I want to remind you Jimmy Carter
turned over his peanut farm to a blind
trust when he became president because
it was considered a possible conflict of
interest there might be something
related to peanut farming in Georgia I
assume the farm was in that could come
up for Jimmy Carter as president and he
turned over his involvement and control
in that peanut farm to a blind trust
while he was president of the United
States Donald Trump is straight up
making money from diplomats who stay at
his hotel and instead of it causing a
problem for him he has the Justice
Department reinterpreting the
Constitution to allow this to happen
it's pond scum corruption it is the
definition of a kleptocracy it's
happening daily and I don't want to be
cynical but it's not very likely that
anything is going to be done about it